and the queen makes her journey
come to an end with this route down
the royal mile
foreign
what's wrong
[Applause]
the queen passes the high kirk offs and
giles where
tomorrow she will lie in state
and also the murkett cross where in 1952
her father the king's death was
announced in the start of her reign too
her proclamation and today
we saw the proclamation of her son
the new king
[Applause]
comments
all right
the
cobbled street
of
this royal mile which will turn into the
cannon gate shortly will bring the queen
to the abbey strand gate
into
the forecourt of hollyrood palace
waiting for
the late queen there will be
the guard of honor
provided by the royal regiment of
scotland
and the king's color will be lowered in
salute to the late queen
no band will play
and when the hearse comes to a halt
the officer commanding the bearer party
will move forward
and her late majesty will be lifted from
the hearse
and born into the palace
along the colonnade inside
the courtyard
and then up to the great stair
and the coffin placed
in the throne room
palace that she left
only at the end of june earlier this
year
looking up from
the start of abby strand gate
up the hill awaiting the queen
being brought down past the cannon gate
kirk where when she was in edinburgh she
regularly again attended divine service
and where her granddaughter
zara phillips was married
me
it is so difficult to believe that the
sparkly-eyed happy enthusiastic
courteous queen who came
on that morning of the 27th of june this
year
to the very place where she will halt
today
is returned in this particular manner so
soon
but scotland has welcomed her home
she's passed through this
long and interesting journey through the
highlands
and finally
we see her come home to her palace
here
beside the parliament building that was
built in her reign
to be received
and to rest in private overnight
foreign